it's January 2025 you get sworn in uh
you're the new president of the United
States um what is top of the list in
terms of the things that you want to
express or get done let me start with
the most important which is how I will
lead and I'm going to lead very
differently I'm going to have a Team of
Rivals in the White House Andrew uh not
unlike Abraham Lincoln put together uh
in the 1860s during the worst crisis in
American history to that point the Civil
War he recognized that every American
had to have their voice inside the White
House he needed to put people at that
table who had different perspectives but
had to lead the country together and I
think it's time for every single future
president of the United States to ensure
that he or she does not just populate
the White House staff and cabinet with
people who all see things the same way I
think that's actually destructive to
democracy and it is destroying the
country that's one I'll also have a
youth cabinet it's time to bring young
people's voices into the White House a
delegate from every one of the 50 states
all Races religions colors back
backgrounds uh and politics and
geographies uh to come up with great
ideas about social media regulation
about uh the future of AI both the
blessings and the curses climate change
gun violence prevention the things that
young people are most focused on for
good reason and have great ideas about
I'm going to employ zerob based
budgeting I'm going to finally have
every single agency of the United States
federal government assessed by an
outside consulting firm to identify ways
to save money deliver Services better
more eff efficiently and effectively
and finally the Pentagon will pass an
audit these are absolutes as the next
leader I'd be the broad I'd have the
most experience Andrew strangely enough
of any recent president having built and
led companies having served as the board
chair of a large Health System uh a
regent at a university a board chair of
a charitable Foundation a board member
of a public company and now three terms
in the United States Congress a member
of House Democratic Leadership ranking
member of the Middle East subcommittee
on Foreign Affairs and also the vice
ranking member of the small business
committee I have very broad experience
and I will use that management
experience which very few occupants of
the White House have had to lead better
uh and most of all to develop Common
Ground if we do not repair the country
use common sense and decency and restore
faith in government nothing I talk about
right now is going to matter so what's
next affordability affordability and
affordability there is a massive
disconnect between Washington and the
rest of the country it's it's it's
staggering how desperate people are
right now housing if you can even find
it is unaffordable mortgage rates have
soared people cannot afford to buy new
homes we are seven six and a half
million units shy to meet the demand in
the United States and we have about a
half a million human beings Americans
sleeping outside every single night not
just New York and San Francisco up here
in Manchester New Hampshire veterans
sleeping in the Parks it's atrocious and
we have to do a 7 million unit
initiative immediately to produce
housing in America Healthcare 66% of
every of all bankruptcies in the United
States are from medical debt from
medical debt in the United States of
America we spend twice as much as any
developed nation in the world our
outcomes are mid-pack we allow and I
state that again we allow pharmaceutical
companies to sell their products in the
United States for three four five times
more than anywhere in the world when I'm
President we will find a way working
together to ensure that none of those
companies can sell their products here
for a penny more than they do in Canada
Mexico Great Britain France or Japan or
Australia period it's not that hard and
we're going to change the delivery model
from a fee for service to a capitation
model so we actually get away from what
we what is really a sick care system we
don't have health care it's a sick care
system so that's Healthcare and then we
have education $1.7 trillion in student
debt uh at 5% interest that's about 80
some billion dollars a year that's
burdening families and young people who
can barely get ahead and we've need
tuition-free college we also need to
make sure that the debt that exists
right now I believe should be interest
free and we should absolve the debt of
any person who is willing to develop
their credentials or career in something
that serves the public so these are
common sense Solutions and then
groceries you know Andrew I you know I
come from the Vodka business when I was
in that business retailers were not
allowed legally could not charge us what
they call slotting fees those are the
prices you pay to rent the Shelf to put
your products on the Shelf but in the
grocery business when I was in the ice
cream business not only can they charge
you all the grocery chains around the
country are charging rent to the bread
makers and the butter makers and the
cereal makers to put your products on
the Shelf so why do we have high grocery
prices of course it's obvious we have
too little competition and we have a
system not unlike the political
industrial complex the duopoly uh that
is literally making things more
expensive than necessary so if we don't
address these things and we don't raise
the foundation uh we are going to be in
big trouble and by the way uh I know you
are a big fan of Ubbi I'm looking at a
bill right now that would do a pilot
around the country because I think AI is
going to almost require that we
completely change the lens of us
capitalism if we hope to remain a
democracy for many many years to come so
those things are on my mind border
security is on my mind chaos in our
cities is on my mind and probably most
importantly if we do not become a
country that ensures security for every
American and peace and prosperity in the
United States and overseas uh we are not
doing our jobs and I'm just afraid the
current generation of leaders from the
West Bank all the way to the West Wing
have got to be replaced with Next
Generation leaders who understand what's
coming who have a different worldview
different competencies and most of all
are ready to work together to solve
problems stop fighting each other and
start fighting for each other that's my
agenda it's not rocket science it's
entirely Common
Sense hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops thank
you